hi I'm Megan Dueck co-founder and chief
scientific officer of combinati
combinati is a San Francisco Bay Area
based biotech hardware company so I
wanted to talk to you today about
improving cancer tracking through the
precision quantification of circulating
nucleic acid biomarkers so there's a lot
of words there and I think I have a
potentially very diverse audience so I
wanted to start very basic so I'm
guessing most of you out there or a lot
of you out there already know this term
liquid biopsy so what is liquid biopsy
just so we start on the same page so a
standard biopsy is an invasive procedure
where you're taking a sample of tissue
that is often not easily obtained and
they're just gonna be some sort of pain
or risk involved and the liquid biopsy
is going to be taking a simple blood
draw usually around 10 milliliters and
using that blood to do some sort of
comprehensive profile of the state of
your cancer it's minimally invasive and
doesn't come with much pain or risk so
what is circulating cell-free DNA so
this is extracellular DNA that's found
in the blood and it's generally derived
from dying or dead cells and there's two
acronyms that are often used CF DNA or
sometimes also see CF DNA is referring
to the total circulating cell-free DNA
and then CT DNA is circulating tumor DNA
and this CT DNA is only a very small
fraction of the overall cell-free DNA so
if a patient has cancer some of that
cancer DNA is going to be floating
around in their blood but it's going to
be less than 1% of the overall
background circulating DNA and so for
early cancer detection and intervention
we want to be able to
detect this circulating tumor DNA
biomarker at a very low concentration
within that total circulating cell free
DNA so to be more specific let's say I
want to quantify down to ten copies and
buy copies I mean ten individual
molecules of a very specific cancer DNA
biomarker per milliliter of blood ten
molecules in a milliliter so how could
this possibly possibly do this so here's
an analogy so let's say I want to find
Waldo in this picture and I've got all
these other humans present you know
let's say I even have a chemistry where
I could I could throw at this picture
somehow and look for that Waldo but I've
got all these other competing humans in
this picture that might mess up my
analysis so instead what if I broke this
picture up into thousands of little
compartments and looked at each
individual compartment now I'm only
comparing Waldo to maybe one or two
other people and that allows me to zero
in and find that Waldo if I just look at
this one picture it's obvious well those
right there so that's sort of more or
less how digital PCR works so again I
know I have potentially diverse audience
I think that many of you out there
probably know what regular PCR is so
regular PCR is a chemistry by which you
can take a single molecule of a specific
DNA sequence and amplify it to the point
where we can detect fluorescence okay so
if you look at the the leftmost square
in this image you see that I've got one
little piece of blue DNA that we're
gonna call our target in this background
of red DNA's if I want to count the blue
DNA's in this background of red what I
can do is
I can divide up the fluid sample into
many different compartments or
partitions such that each compartment is
fluidic li isolated and now each of
these compartments is going to have in
all likelihood zero of my targets or one
molecule of my target that's where the
name digital comes from if I then run a
reaction that's going to turn my target
fluorescent that's in the third Square
from the left I can see that only the
ones that contained my target to begin
with turn green and then I can basically
just count the number of compartments
that turned green and I have molecule
resolution DNA quantification so this is
what digital PCR is and it's incredibly
powerful so here's sort of my view and
an oversimplification of how to turn
cancer into a manageable disease so it
requires accurate diagnosis and then
some sort of effective treatment and
then continuous monitoring now as much
as I love digital PCR and think that
it's really going to revolutionize
cancer treatment for patients it's not
the perfect technology for all three of
these things so next generation
sequencing I think is an incredibly
powerful tool and I do think is the
proper technology to use for accurate
diagnosis and initial characterization
of a patient's cancer effective
treatment different PCR is not a
treatment technology so of course we're
not the technology for that you know in
this instance I would maybe say that
immuno therapy is maybe the direction or
the technology that I would bank on for
effective treatment but then once the
patient is given a treatment that
patient needs to be monitored with
absolute precision in in a timely manner
so as often as possible and it's not a
one-time thing these two things it's
not a single direction I guess I should
say so
once a patient is on a treatment its
thoughtful that that treatment will
continue to work and you need to be able
to know that that will cause treatment
monitoring but in some cases the patient
is going to acquire resistance to that
treatment you need to diagnose that
early as well and that can cause a
physician to change the treatment
regimen
perhaps a patient will go into total
molecular remission in which case the
patient's going to need to be monitored
for recurrence all of these things need
absolute quantification of miniscule DNA
biomarkers so to put it in another
example here let's say that this plot on
the y-axis is your cancer signals
floating around in your blood so you're
circulating tumor DNA and let's say a
patient has gone into remission and
they've been treated and the cancer DNA
biomarkers have gone to zero so that's
gonna be at the far left corner of my
plot here so I want to monitor this
patient with as high resolution as
possible to detect the moment that that
cancer starts coming back so and by
doing this we can adjust cancer
treatment early we can implement a new
treatment faster and we can improve
patient outcomes so a lot of people
think that next-generation sequencing is
the proper technology to use for this
but there's actually an increasing
amount of literature coming out showing
that while next-generation sequencing is
great for characterization and providing
us with a lot of genetic information
about a patient there quantification
sensitivity for specific small fraction
DNA biomarkers is actually not very good
so this recent paper actually showed
that when you get below a 1% mutant to
wild-type ratio the quantification is
just
accurate anymore and for the type of
sensitivity that cancer patients need we
really need to decrease that down to
point one percent or lower and this is
the type of sensitivity that digital PCR
offers alright so hopefully I've
convinced you that digital PCR is the
go-to technology for cancer monitoring
so let's get let's get into the hardware
requirements for this technology so for
digital PCR you have two fluidic alee
isolate your individual DNA biomarkers
that you want to quantify so how do you
do this fluidic isolation so we're
isolating individual molecules of DNA
biomarkers so to to explain this I
wanted to talk briefly about the
evolution of digital PCR so PCR first
was published in 1988 this was a PCR
polymerase chain reaction revolutionized
molecular biology and then in 1999
vogelstein at all published the first
real digital PCR paper where they used
limiting dilution to isolate individual
target molecules using standard
microtiter plates so if you dilute down
a PCR sample enough you can achieve
there's no PCR in a 96-well plate for
example this is not very scalable though
in 2006 the first commercially available
digital PCR platform became available
this was a micro fluidics platform
it required complex valves in order to
do the fluidic isolation and it suffered
several things that I think kept it from
becoming the market leader in digital
PCR and then in 2012 a platform became
available that uses droplets to do this
fluidic isolation so instead of having
little wells now you have
or DNA molecules of interest isolated
via droplets and what I'm going to talk
about is my personal company and why we
think we're going to revolutionize
digital PCR and we do use micro fluidics
once again but our instrument or our
consumable rather does not require
complex
valving or any sort of films or user
actuated steps to do this fluidic
isolation so my company is called
combinati and this is actually an SEM
image of our consumable and you can see
these little compartments that look kind
of like ice cube trays and in these
compartments is where we're going to
isolate our PCR targets of interest so
why do I think so I'm what I'm gonna
call this is a ray based digital PCR
versus droplet based so why do I think
that our injection molded array is
potentially better than the droplet
systems so first of all the droplet
systems are inherently very complex they
require at present three instruments to
run we have a very streamlined workflow
that only requires one instrument and so
we're really trying to make this as
simple as possible to make it as
accessible as possible for all
clinicians are trying to answer it's
going to be faster because of this
simplified workflow we're gonna get
physicians and patients sample answer in
under an hour
we also waste less sample and this makes
us we think more efficient and now these
bottom two real-time imaging and melt
ready I'm gonna guess maybe most of you
out there have no idea what I'm talking
about with those two so I wanted to talk
a bit about what those two potential
benefits are and these are two things
that cannot be done with droplets that
are that we definitely can accomplish
with an injection-molded
array all right so first
wanted to show you a picture of the
combinati digital PCR consumable and
they zoom in of some actual data from
our consumable and in this image you can
see that there are glowing green spots
and then there are sort of red
background spots the glowing green spots
are gonna be where my target molecule
existed so those are compartments where
I had that target molecule of interest
I ran the PCR chemistry and now those
partitions are glowing green the red are
it's a just a dye showing that those
compartments did in fact get loaded with
reagents and sample but did not contain
my target of interest now what you call
an image like this is an in the point
image so I I ran the PCR cycle and this
is what my endpoint looks like hmm
apologies I'm getting over a little bit
cold nothing Starbucks politics mmm so
this is great endpoint analysis is
awesome and this is what the droplet
based systems do and we can do great
things with endpoint analysis so this is
an example of data generated with our
system here we quantified a very common
cancer mutation EGFR t7 90 M in a
background of wild-type DNA and what we
show here you look at the bottom right
table we are able to quantify down to
0.13% mutant DNA in a background of
wild-type and this is the sort of
sensitivity we need and this was
actually done with some mock circulating
cell free DNA samples generated by sera
care and was actually just presented at
ACR 2019 so this was all done with
endpoint i'm not going to discount the
power of endpoint digital PCR
it's fantastic but there's also a lot of
potential to be realized in monitoring
digital PCR partitions in real time so
this endpoint analysis it's great but
what if I need to monitor multiple DNA
markers in the same patient sample and
this is a this is a thing that doctors
want physicians often want to monitor
panels of 10 or more DNA biomarkers in a
cancer patient sample and one strategy
for doing that is something called milk
curve analysis and for those of you
familiar with PCR you've likely heard of
this using both PCR so in this chemistry
you you used for example a intercalating
die like evergreen and this dye goes
into my PCR product and then if I look
at the bottom-left graph what I'm
showing our two separate PCR targets so
in the in the case of cancer I can think
of these as two different cancer
mutations so if I take that endpoint
product so this is all done after PCR
thermal cycling so that endpoint image I
just showed you this would be run after
that so I would take that endpoint image
and I would slowly raise the temperature
and then monitor the fluorescence in
those partitions and ask the floor as
the temperature is increased the dye is
going to leave the DNA molecules and
eventually the signal is going to go
down to zero and depending on the PCR
target you are going to get different
fluorescence EK dynamics so here you can
see in the PCR target one which is the
redline I have a certain fluorescence DK
dynamics and PCR target - I have a
different one and it may not look very
substantial there but another way to
look at it is to plot the negative slope
of these curves and then I get these
nice Peaks and now the differences are
quite noticeable all right so what does
this have to do with our system so
multiplexing via melt curve analysis is
not possible in droplet based digital
PCR systems because it requires the
ability to take real-time
images of digital PCR partitions over
time and droplets the way that the
current market leading digital PCR
system works is it reads droplets in a
flow cytometry types fashion and so once
you read a droplet it's gone and there's
some other strategies where people have
tried to array droplets but the droplets
still new and so tracking them over time
is still a is still difficult it's not
ideal and so if we have a physical array
where the partitions aren't moving at
all we can do really high-resolution
fluorescence monitoring of those
partitions so to put it in another way
or a more specific example so let's say
that I have three PCR products blue
yellow and red for the purposes of this
example and let's say all three of these
PCR products have different melt
temperatures so you can see PCR products
one has the melt temperature of what
we're calling t1 PCR product 2 has a
melt temperature we're calling t2 and
PCR product 3 has a melt we're calling
t3 all right so if I happen to put all
of these PCR products together into the
same tube alright actually let's go back
just one step so even though I'm
coloring this blue piece our product one
blue and PCR product two yellow and
three red in reality they're all going
to have that green fluorescent signal
for this example okay so if I put them
all together in one one tube the tube is
going to if I run the PCR chemistry the
tube is going to fluoresce green but I'm
not gonna know if that became if that
green came from product one if it came
from product to or if it came from
product three if all three were present
in that tube I'm gonna get melt dynamics
that look something like this
bottom-left graph where you can see each
individual target melting discreetly if
I talk if I do this in a digital you
know array
based digital PCR context so that's what
I'm trying to depict in the bottom right
here so let's say that the the white
circles those are going to be the PCR
partitions that didn't have any of these
targets and then I see a variety of
other colors but in reality if these
were real data these would all just be
green they would all be the same color
and I wouldn't know if they had PCR
products one if they had two or three or
some combination of those three all
right so what I can do is I can take
that already and I can raise the
temperature just above t1 and now all of
the PCR products one targets are going
to melt and by melt I mean their
fluorescence is going to go away you can
see the blue dots have gone away so in
reality that would be a little bit of
green fluorescence going away in any
partition where I saw a decrease in
green fluorescence those partitions had
PCR product one alright so now I can
take that same array increase the
temperature just pass t2 and I'm gonna
see my yellow PCR product go away
so any difference in fluorescence here
I'm gonna say that partition at PCR
product number two I think you know
where I'm going next we're gonna raise
the temperature just past e3 and now I'm
gonna see any partitions with
fluorescence left over that signal
should now go away and those partitions
contain the PCR product three and it's
actually already been shown that you can
train a computer to recognize up to a
hundred different melt curve signatures
if you monitor those melt curves with
high enough resolution so you can see
this very messy overwhelming plots down
here in the right corner if the aren't
very human to make out the differences
there but a computer can do that for us
apologies
and if you were wondering combinati has
already done some proof of concept
experiments to show that we can do this
this particular slide is showing ABC are
able assay for chronic myeloid leukemia
recurrence monitoring so VCR Abel is a
fusion transcript that is very common
it's it's a signature of chronic myeloid
leukemia and often physicians want to
monitor both the BCR Abel fusion and
also the wild-type Abel and so in this
particular assay there were four
possibilities so if I run this assay
with and I want to quantify wild-type
Abel and BCR Abel and I run the sample
out in a array the partitions in that
array are either going to be negative
for both targets they're going to have
wild-type Abel target or they're gonna
have the BCR Abel fusion target or
they're gonna have both targets and so
what we need to be able to do is
distinguish between these three
possibilities and these three bottom
graphs are examples of these so these
curves were generated from individual
digital PCR partitions so these are very
small partitions where we can monitor
the fluorescence and generate curves for
the fluorescence decay and you can see
that we can easily distinguish between a
partition that has wild-type Abel a
partition that has a bcr-abl fusion and
a partition that has both and I suppose
I should have actually added to this
slide one more chart showing just a flat
line for a partition that has none of
these three so you'll just have to
believe me that that's indeed what it
does look like and with that that
concludes my presentation and so I hope
I've convinced you that multiplexed
monitoring of miniscule circulating
tumor DNA biomarkers through array based
you'll PCR truly holds the key to better
patient outcomes and better cancer
discoveries and yeah thank you for your
time I welcome any and all questions
feel free to submit your questions and I
will get back to you via email as
quickly as I can and we're also open to
collaborations if you happen to be a
researching some sort of cancer or any
other technology or science that would
be benefited from digital PCR all right
I hope to hear from some of you guys and
thank you so much